as the Russians Retreat from communities
in her song residents are left with
reminders of their stay
a swathe of Destruction in towns and
Villages like valleca alexandrithika
it can be difficult to take it all in
this quiet community spent months on the
front line
and the fire chief suggested we
investigate the local school
he led us into an underground room and
we could see it had been used by the
Russians
we saw lewd graffiti and the letter Z
the symbol of Russia's war in Ukraine
along with the date the Russians took
over this town 2602
fire chief the Vladimir beckoned us into
the gloom and we realized it was more
than just a bomb shelter
this community school had been turned
into a military base
foreign
how many soldiers
live down here do you think
you think at least 200
actually
this Subterranean Labyrinth had been
dressed in soft Furnishings the
occupants seemingly planning to stay
it's very strange there are a dozen
rooms down here maybe more and they've
all been decorated with this tent-like
effect
the soldiers have been
trying to make it look like home I think
there were multiple kitchens and places
to eat
and some items look surprisingly
luxurious we found perfumes and silk
bedding
members of this Garrison made a swift
departure but some have threatened to
return
it's interesting this this message left
on the wall down here says soon
will return soon we'll come back
sinister
the war was fought on the upper three
floors in a school that had been turned
into a fortress
the classrooms were sandbagged with
occasional slits so the Russians could
fire their weapons
the school library deployed as a blast
wall
and there were putanesque views scrolled
on the walls come and take a look at
this this is the English language room
and see what they've done to the map of
Great Britain the UK and Ireland had
been covered with a zed Plus rossia or
Russia at the bottom
it's sad isn't it I mean the school's
been trashed
um
yeah
but it will cost hundreds of billions of
pounds to rebuild this country and the
conflict goes on
most residents fled before the Russian
occupation but those who stayed have
been marked by it Tatiana told us the
soldiers were only boys
did you feel sorry for them
foreign
this unpopular War may have come to a
close in this town at least
but the battle to the south for the city
of her son will be Savage
joy in Liberation must be balanced with
the pain
John Sparks Sky News in valleca
alexandrika